what's going on there citizens of the reject
Nation we are going to do a first time watching
for a movie I've been clamoring to see for
a very long time and that is called Jennifer's
Body I am rejoined by the world girl herself
Roxy the straw Roxy how are you wow I got
a duh I like that only big people get those
the Australia Destroyer you're a big person
today huge huge anyway Jennifer's Body you
have not seen this movie right no and honestly
I don't think I ever lie about having seen
movies but I think I've been lying about having
seen this movie for years because it's just
so not cool to have not seen it uh people
just kind of pester you if you say you haven't
seen this so people will be like oh you've
seen it I'm like oh it's dope sweet welcome
to the not cool Club ladies and Gentlemen
please go ahead use your body to maneuver
your way to that like button see how I did
that also you'd be a real fox if you can subscribe
and leave click that notification Bell fumble
the delivery there and and uh you know um
patreon we got full length ratchet and watch
alongs re-sync up with your own copy of Jennifer's
Body we're watching this off hippo Max today
cover several things exclusive over there
with reaction hats Watch Dogs included more
importantly if you want her to come back you
gotta follow her on the world girls that's
the only compromise we have made today oh
yeah we shook on it so this will be awkward
if you guys don't hook it up and she needs
at least five followers and I think we can
accomplish that I'm counting slowly over my
tears one all right two don't make me keep
going four [__] roll that intro
[Music]
Disney Disney's Jennifer's party the family
of classic I love how we chose this movie
today could have done a much bigger movie
but what would Jennifer's Body
she's got like a hole in her arm what's going
on there like a burn Maybe
oh I hate that just chewing her hair oh I
hate that little kids do that wow for only
five seconds
pretty font it might be a rom-com Fall Out
Boy hello yeah I see you wanted to touch it
not touching the show what the hell
oh is this like hell is a teenage girl remember
in the future I guess I'm not exactly perfect
myself
but at least I have my fans that's how Roxy
says on Twitter that's Amanda sacred speaking
right now yeah I mean I get letters every
day mostly from perverts and Chesters but
still this is my floor I'm kind of the [__]
got it Queen Rick time started five minutes
ago needy gracias rimondo I used to make these
oh so you really are her they tell me everything
will be okay if I just accept Jesus Christ
into my heart that's true he was a Jew I say
the words but nothing ever happens nobody
comes back it's because you got to believe
I've been trying to convert this one for ages
well those JV tactics won't work against me
her first name is needy I'm the kicker I'm
not sure Tolson could provide sufficient energy
during your day I recommend more complex cobbler
whoa kicker indeed I recommend you shut the
[__] up
oh my God oh damn kicker
oh I did not know what this movie was
it's a movie about mental health it used to
be normal well as normal as any girl under
the influence of teenage hormones she does
have Golem eyes but after the killings began
I started to feel loose around the edges or
something it's weird that this is so known
as Megan Fox's movie and not Amanda seyfritz
at all I hate this song
this is where it all went down this does have
like an 80s movie Vibe it feels 90s to me
the place is just named after a waterfall
like Heathers and [__] like that it goes
into this hole and it doesn't come out scientist
guys dropped all kinds of things down there
but nothing ever surfaces oh maybe it's another
dimension you could drop bodies down there
just two months ago me Jennifer and my boyfriend
Chip were completely normal people
what do you think about devil as a mascot
I think it's satanic and Antichrist people
found it hard to believe that a babe like
Jennifer would associate with a dork like
me I mean you're pretty attractive looking
dork yeah blue shoulder playing at Melody
Lane or this indie rock band from the city
I saw their Myspace page and the lead singers
extra salty
salty like not bitter but they get up at 8
30. wear something cute okay okay damn she
looks exactly the same today interesting sounds
like you're judging her physical appearance
no she's so hot both places those jeans are
hell low I can almost see your front butt
this boy looks 12. I know this is my rock
look well I can see like your womb so you
don't know where her womb is honey you guys
go to Devil's Kettle high school anyway the
singer Guy Jennifer says he's extra salty
so salty salty salty whatever salty means
beautiful is that what it means you must be
soy sauce babe oh good one pick up line of
the year that's why you're the drummer we
missed Valentine's Day for that we need to
quit shampooing yourself and get down here
that's [__] weird tamponing yourself this
real slang it's just that I like the same
things that she likes we have stuff in common
that's why we're biffs oh oh hi chip it smells
like Thai food in here have you guys been
oh my God
this is weird it's like a bingo hall with
Taps they're just Jello because you're not
invited Jello you're totally Jello you're
lime green Jello and you can't even admit
it to yourself yup Jello [__] stop kidnapping
my girlfriend your lime green Jello and you
can't even admit it something tells me Chip's
gonna die this movie you look really pretty
he thinks he's cute enough for me and that's
why he's in return that
aged well hey it's Ahmed from India I wonder
if he's circumcised I always want to try sea
cucumber Jennifer check poison yourself addiction
is that Christmas we only do arrest you have
a possession you're not even out of the academy
at Roman two more months then I'm on the force
for reals you gonna cuff me oh don't do that
I can't get over this hey that's the band
[Music] I I had no idea Chris Pratt was in
this movie okay Adam Brody Adams highlighter
they're wearing eyeliner yeah
you're a small time Gummer I wish we had more
guys like that until it's cuddle small time
what I I don't know most of the dialogue I
was a teenage girl I don't know what they're
saying and I think around this time this movie's
made me an old man I don't know what they're
talking about these are like smart bombs Point
them in the right direction and [__] gets
real okay really smart bombs huh shoulder
yeah we've heard I've heard about you you
player instrument s really super good why
would you want to play all the way out here
in Devil's Kettle I think it's really important
sometimes to try and connect with our fans
in them shitty there it is too can I buy you
a drink sure what are we having this Diet
Pepsi red white and blue but you have to drink
it really fast or it turns brownish all right
we'll drink it fast you can't get alcohol
though oh honey I got to be 21. I'll just
play hello video with a bartender yeah oh
like I said I've been a teenage girl and I'm
a 45 year old man trying to understand Jennifer's
Body today how's she gonna get the alcohol
though her smart bombs did you miss that wow
you're Green Jello man the one who just went
to give me a drink the state fair butter princess
that's the one my point is school's definitely
a virgin these shots are so interesting your
powers
it's my best friend that you're talking about
oh nice she is a virgin and that beats sleeping
with creeps like you got it girl he's sour
I think the lead singer wants me only because
he thinks that you're a virgin I heard them
talking what I'm not even a back door virgin
anymore wow I couldn't even go to Flags the
next day I had to stay home and sit on a bag
of frozen peas
they're both excellent I know I actually think
Megan Fox is really good in this she's always
been really good she got so screwed by Hollywood
and Amanda Seyfried is like just so incredible
did you see the job out of course not Roxy
you're a loss I've seen Ted 2.
when I don't think he's really singing [Music]
I kind of do he's very breathy do you think
he's salty yeah I mean I'm a big OC girl [Music]
[Applause] that tattoo
oh she does have feelings for her huh oh yeah
they're obviously both into each other
oh oh no don't pull away she's afraid why
did it turn her hand green
oh
she's got this like really subtle sexiness
Stillness to her Megan Fox for the win I don't
see it
oh now it's a concert Devil's cattle
oh [__] oh no oh no is this really happening
right now
I know where to go the exit door use your
smart bombs this way
wow Jennifer you didn't really seem to react
to all that violence yes she's in love
Jennifer oh thank God you guys are all right
I've been looking everywhere for you too
oh I wonder if he's a baddie I want us to
get to a familiar place okay this one's in
shock isn't that
he really pushed the drink
you think he was like vampire glaring her
let's go the van I want to go to your really
cool van Nene literally take her from the
van
you should let your friend go in the van
awful no yeah obviously obviously skinny and
twisted and evil like this petrified tree
I saw when I was a kid oh my God you never
let your friend get in the van
yes just like that tree
yeah the way a shot does have this like late
80s early 90s Vibe about it it's kind of like
a Cruel Intentions Flair totally this is crazy
Jennifer they took her in their spooky fan
with the windows all blacked out did you get
the making model
cheese and Fries there's a very specific Style
there's
like a rock Gothic Flair so strange maybe
I'm going crazy
scream energy let's go
yeah so much has happened in the last 20 minutes
that Jello that's my new nickname for you
for yellow
I would at least grab a weapon Like a Knife
yeah anything baseball bat these all qualify
as weapons
grab some jello
where are your parents [Music]
boom whoa she got turned yo
this is just another night with her on MGK
man what happened saying he didn't cheat but
I feel like I don't know Chad
thank you was she looking for beer jello oh
she needs meat my mom got that at Boston Market
um
Boston Market slabs
bones babe
[Applause]
oh Wicked
she cold
oh
scared
I'd be a little scared too yeah good
[Music]
foreign 's been thrashing her around
I wonder what the vampire rules are in this
movie is that what you're thinking is happening
I thought this was a vampire but that's all
I ever heard about it oh okay then I'm with
you I also knew this was a vampire movie Incredible
I hope you called the cops oh I'm Jennifer
[Music] really relatable don't tell my mom
about this I never tell on you they're besties
BFF the necklace where's it at Monistat you
were to have a tendency to overreact you remember
when we were in Girl Scout camp and you totally
thought that there was an earthquake but it
was just two guys with a ghetto blaster a
what she's gaslighting people died Jennifer
anybody that we know we know everyone
sucks to be them I guess Savage what is wrong
with you what's wrong with you besides the
obvious surface flaws wow I knew it was real
I'd been up all night scrubbing the Carnage
off the linoleum why to hide for her friend
if that's not effective this is a dark dark
day for a Devil's Kettle JK Simmons interesting
we lost eight precious students including
Ahmed from India several parents she wanted
to suck as well laughs now more than ever
but aside your teenage concerns about who's
a cool dude or who's a hoe
who's a cool dude who's a hoe are you a teacher
what's the choice there was it because of
the fire no I think it's used to always added
some weird questions she barfed up this like
disgusting prickly stuff that looked like
a roadkill and like so many needles mixed
together
she probably just inhaled a whole bunch of
smoke or something yeah this guy it was like
evil ship has no smart balloons that's why
he's so dumb not saying that to be a dill
hole ship I don't tell Whoppers and I'm not
crazy I didn't say you were crazy what are
these kids saying I don't tell Whoppers hey
Nene oh hi Colin whoa who's this guy who looks
familiar well I'm glad you didn't die thanks
seriously not even a dressing chip how are
you friends with Colin Gray I just damn we've
created non-fiction together he's a really
good writer he's like all dark and emotional
emotions love him have a secret I'm like that
too I'm American related no chip honey not
all obvious about it like a poser yep you're
boring yep know yourself
who's this guy we saw him once before for
a second
hi what the hell Craig said that he always
thought you and me would make a totally banging
couple so that's so weird which one was Craig
I think it was Chris Pratt oh yeah what up
Craig I feel my heart Jonas I think it's broken
mine too oh this will help him grief it's
what Craig would have wanted
yeah ah Craig's a good guy oh she's gonna
kill him I believe that's where this is headed
look at this lucky actor yeah totally he'll
have this for the rest of his life I know
he just watches it every day why are you so
warm studies
shutties that means shut up if you didn't
know oh okay shutties
I can't do it with these animals watching
us what oh look mosquito the blood from the
mosquito
oh my God it's like Snow White
they're waiting for
movie rated PG
oh might be a hard PG-13
oh God
grief is a [__] let it all out kids if
you heard that and you were a teacher would
you go running probably I have a hook for
a hand too
just hope we hope we are courage here in our
upcoming album oh so he's still alive huh
yeah why wouldn't he be he's the perp
I don't know whether I mean wow
you dream about
dream some bad people were trying to nail
you to a tree with hammers and Big Steaks
and [__] okay
this movie is awesome
come on come on I know come on just show a
little bit would you
just love that she went randomly swimming
in the lake I feel so scrumptious for you
you should be happy for me because I am having
the best day since like Jesus invented the
calendar Jesus didn't invent the calendar
yes he did you take that back they're lying
hold on so blow it off it'll just be a minute
who's the needy one now hey I need to see
you right now barely hear you knock it off
Camille
what that's like the famous gift is it yeah
I've never seen that you've never seen people
do a Halloween costume and they always have
the lighter no that is really dangerous and
stupid for people to do that I gotta go I
am a god okay fiery death trip last night
and now a cannibal psycho takes down the biggest
guy in school come on it's [__]
it's not freaked freaked hearted [Laughter]
you're shaking oh I'm cold it's very cold
out here keep them warm you want my hoodie
oh chip is useless our Town's only bar had
burned to the ground and our star linebacker
was someone's Snack Pack this whole country
got a huge tragedy boner for Devil's Kettle
oh [Music]
the flowers showing the passing of time
what are these random people they focus on
I know like chip we figured things could only
get better we had Faith jokes on you life
is tough we were [__] idiots yep through
the trees has become our unofficial Anthem
they have decided to release it as a benefit
single oh no what's going on they used us
you take that back needyless Nikki girls we
need them now more than ever that's enough
clever what a way to become famous I'm already
sick of that song yeah it's really poorly
pretty do you think they put fake pimples
on Megan Fox's face yeah there's no way the
real Megan Fox grows pimples impossible my
skin is breaking out and my hair is dull and
lifeless still looks so hot it's like I'm
one of the normal girls nope never possible
to look normal are you PMSing or something
PMS isn't real needy it was invented by the
boy run media to make us seem crazy take notes
take notes I actually wanted to uh to ask
you something you want to know if I'll go
out with you no I don't how did you just go
ahead with the pitch [Laughter] okay um oh
I feel bad there's a midnight showing of Rocky
Horror at The Bijou next weekend like boxing
movies
he's into maggot rock he wears nail polish
my bigger than that well I think he's really
cool you do come by my place I just got aquamarine
on DVD it's about this girl who's like half
sushi I guess she has sex to a blue hole or
something
kill him because because needy thinks he's
cool or and trap him for needy oh well she
loves needy she wants needy hmm hi chip kill
chip so I'm talking to your mysterious pal
Colin Gray again no he was asking Jennifer
out on a date that's weird it is weird sure
I'd like that I went to Super Target and picked
up more condoms so thanks nice dude have they
had sex I don't think so I think he just keeps
buying condoms and he keeps having to throw
them out but is she a backdoor virgin uh we
can Google it really if you want it's Jim
and Jasmine my mom has holiday sense too this
is nice she really likes him I know and he's
so I can't wait for him to die
he's like Ashton Kutcher hey don't don't diminish
Ashton Kutcher I do love Ashton Kutcher [Music]
oh he's gonna die right now I know it's gonna
be beautiful
where is she bringing him to
why is he seem so concerned because because
the lighting in the neighborhood changed okay
I think bring your bandana just in case bud
it does look a little suspicious it's really
dark here make her come outside that's Megan
Fox be worth the risk yeah full for sure yeah
it doesn't matter I don't care bring me to
a graveyard yeah take me to a morgue I don't
care
Oh weird
actually I think I'd turn around now really
you wouldn't see this all the way through
I don't I think I would call text hey your
house seems boarded up
wouldn't do that
oh she's adapted she's going like full Dexter
slippery swirl yeah it's um it's supposed
to make it feel good for the girl oh let's
go chip but what about yourself chip right
you got the wrong mindset my friend I think
chip will be just fine oh it's like a seance
what's going on here ritual
he thinks it's a romantic Ash gesture you
can play mommy and daddy
so far so good honestly yeah might as well
do you even know my last why are you doing
this you give me such a wetty already what
does that mean I think what I don't know
who's to say though
look at the parallels yeah actually there's
chips growing on me I know he's growing on
someone right now you know what I mean no
what do you mean um I can't explain are you
scared I mean I thought boys like you were
really into Vermin and death and [__]
nice Hardware Ace that was a good one
like a snake oh puncture wound God that's
so emo
I need you frightened
I literally hate watching this oh is she like
connected oh yeah what the hell I think she's
connected in some way to Jennifer because
of what I don't know
[Music]
gnarly I feel bad for the people who had to
light those candles continuity on them it's
tough
uh chip you're misreading this whole situation
chip thinking he's giving a woman thought
he was rocking the hell out of this situation
am I too big yes champ that's the problem
is this something I did
that was a sick shot that's a good effect
damn nice so this is the only real vampire
aspect of her is that she sucks blood I think
well she needs blood to live here but she
doesn't turn anybody into vampires she can
be in the daytime different set of vampire
rules
wow if you're chip right now you're feeling
like butthole it's an interesting movie because
it's like not just a vampire film it's a high
school adolescent film totally 100 of my vibe
no pull it together
I'm up in the car oh I don't know I'm getting
scared wow what an entrance you were right
[Applause]
you're a terrible friend Jennifer
I'm kind of feeling like needy's a little
bit bad friend too why she's gotta help her
bring in an emergency room that won't do anything
all right I'm just gonna go to bed hi
median up with the screaming you're such a
cliche I'm not gonna bite you is that my Evil
Dead t-shirt that's your question yeah yeah
she loves you
good for them but I feel like a needy really
loves the other girl the other girl really
just using her the other girl's name Jennifer
I guess you forgot the name of the movie
Megan's body yeah needy loves Jennifer man
they really had him go at it huh
thing oh my God all right okay so you remember
the night of the fire I got really messed
up and those guys from Low Shoulder totally
evil agents of Satan with a really awesome
haircuts all right let's see what happened
here are you even sure she's a [__] virgin
man oh they have to be virgins to turn them
so they drove me out to the falls and I kept
looking for a way to escape but it's really
dark out there also do you think she's been
going after virgins oh good question we had
a waxing moon tonight you guys just like the
ritual set how interesting so you're like
witchcraft but they're not vampires right
but get it nice and tight though because I
don't want to get [__] clawed oh do they
throw into that hole oh I forgot about the
hole with the ping pong balls you want to
be a big loser or do you want to be rich and
awesome like that guy from Maroon 5. everyone
wants to be like Adam everyone wants to be
maroon 5. we come here tonight to sacrifice
the body of
what's your name again Tiffany my name is
Jennifer super don't tell them
damn nursing Megan Fox act this much she's
good we're going to have to butcher you and
bleach you and then door care is going to
wear your face but because she's not a virgin
she can't be sacrificed
[Applause] [Music]
don't knock your head to this okay
I'm clapping cause I know she's gonna come
back with a vengeance it should have killed
me but for some reason didn't sex saved her
life you hear that kids I woke up and I found
my way back to you
but then you tried to scare her and then you
connected yourself to her how why I couldn't
bring myself to hurt you I mean I'm a really
good friend you said she was a bad friend
are you gonna pay for that windshield huh
good friend would
I meant
you made it up oh no way does your host family
know you're alive
does anyone know you're alive Jennifer hi
when I'm full I'm like unkillable like I can
do [__] like this watch
oh it's really cool just watch look why when
she was eating her own hair I hated that
some X-Men [__] right what do you mean
when you're full you don't need maybe you
should talk to somebody about these disturbing
thoughts ah what a manipulator we're all really
concerned especially chip I think he may be
having second thoughts about you leave why
would you tell her that much for not admit
to eating people I feel like needy should
have read between the lines there oh yeah
definitely what are you doing um you said
to leave see you at school I feel you girl
somebody doesn't want you there you got to
get out she's a little gaslighter that Jennifer
though huh I'm like team Jennifer
something about you in real life you don't
want to be nicknamed needy under any circumstances
the sacrifice isn't pure she should convince
everybody in town to have sex so they're all
not at risk that would be a finale would you
lose your virginity if you heard that you
couldn't die as long as you had sex yeah school-wide
announcement your only safety find him what's
going on you're breaking up with me is this
about Jennifer yes but I promise you this
is the last thing I care about you I don't
think Jed needs to attack virgins though or
do you think she can take out anybody yeah
yeah I think so Jennifer's evil I know I've
been through the occult section at the library
five times my library has an occult section
they're called Devil's Kettle High School
I would have assume it would but the human
sacrifice is impure the result may still be
attained but the demon demon ever reside in
the soul of the victim she must forever feed
on flesh to sustain the demon um so they don't
have to be virgins oh yes the dance be like
an all-you-can-eat buffet
she's having chips on the menu oh nicely done
it's not that I don't believe you I just don't
believe this God this is a nightmare I mean
you sound crazy I wouldn't believe you either
I ordered your corsage it's an orchid it was
like twelve dollars it's pretty good for an
orchid chip it's not safe for us to be together
right now
oh this food is making me feel bad for chip
what happened to chip ladies pepper spray
I can take care of myself I've been using
the Bowflex if your parent you don't let your
kid out right
don't eat it don't eat it don't eat it I really
have a thing against that
oh she like fully transforming she has to
feed and if she doesn't feed she's in trouble
she just fed now that was like yesterday bro
her hair's falling out she needs blood how
often does she need to feed how often do you
need to eat every three to four hours stop
judging Jennifer she didn't she didn't ask
for this
I like that I made up a whole storyline that
she could only kill virgins I kind of just
believed you until the movie clarified they're
just like yeah yeah it's like oh that's crazy
yeah it's made up people at home probably
like nope
wow if he used his other hand he could have
cut his throat open I was thinking that too
welcome to the Supreme forma [Applause] chip
which path did you take to go
I'm confused moms like take pepper spray but
I won't drive you there
can you hear me calling your name you know
how needy has been really upset since Colin
Gray died wild outfit choice I don't want
to say this [__]
needy and Colin were intimate
this is how she's gonna get him to hook up
I mean they were porking on a semi-regular
basis oh that is so messed up she and Colin
were doing things that you have never even
heard of okay total Varsity moves like what
what back doors I want to hear the library
I care about you so much more than I've ever
had the guts too it is oh dude don't fall
for it if you're him what are you doing
I mean he's single now right
no chip no chip [Music] he looks like I'm
Adam Levine wannabe yeah that might be very
intentional Sam better than me what why you're
gonna be so mad at me right now but boys are
so stupid well I'd be mad of course they are
taking a word for it clearly and like maybe
just told him yeah no it's totally obvious
oh she feels it how are they connected like
that I don't understand this [Music] please
man when are they gonna get their comeuppance
they Gotta Die [Music]
put two and two together man one chip show
me a breaststroke
get there babe
she just takes off the whole dress do you
want to see chip die or no ah kind of not
as strong as before
now you can't I'm sorry this just feels weird
oh [__]
well what are you gonna do just yell some
dialogue at her I think
and if he did kiss you again were you gonna
keep him alive
one flower corsage don't stop keep going there's
no rest period here but it's an orchid that's
12 worth of orchid right there
gymnast oh nope yes yes she is
oh there he is [Applause]
ah oh he's gonna bleed out
I try to get out of the water guys try to
warn you chip definitely infected now oh what
would she becoming pepper spray
[Applause]
[Music]
oh no
whoa she got a whole new set of powers here
fly covering yeah it kind of looks dope it's
not that impressive but do you have
you were such a player hater [Laughter] anybody
that you want Jennifer so
you want or is it because you're just really
insecure
I was the snowflake Queen two years ago when
you were socially relevant and you didn't
need laxatives to stay skinny wow get her
I am going to eat your soul and [__] I
thought you only murdered boys I go both ways
whoa chip oh
it didn't seem to do much tampon yeah you
seem like you might be blogging
I'm so happy too oh oh chip gonna die I don't
think so no he's definitely dead oh definitely
said yeah
you have a flip phone use it it's probably
all wet and broken what about hers stop working
no no no you're not going anywhere no second
you're fine honey you're fine I think I already
died before you got here but I woke up when
I heard your voice oh that's actually really
sweet chip I love you I love you too he's
gonna be okay
literally delirious [Music] put Band-Aid on
it [Music] it's fine [Laughter] post credit
scene he's good how are we gonna kill Adam
Brody I don't think the movie's gonna do it
Circle people's picture total hottie I wish
and of course yeah don't eat your hair she
should have gone back to the dance to feed
she didn't need any more you don't understand
how hunger works I think I do
[Music] [Laughter] what is happening you killed
my [__] boyfriend you got that monster
she swore
yo this is Laura it's for cutting boxes yes
I thought it was the more clever
whoa
[Music] What's Happening Here [Music]
oh I wonder if that's what kept them connected
this bait must be [Music] but that's so weird
that that would have whatever I'll accept
it
[Music] grunge
oh no
she's gonna be looked at as just a murderer
now
blood pooling in the neck really good where's
Jennifer's mom oh ask it you shall receive
oh my God
oh that sucks and she has to suffer through
all this now
that does suck and now needy's gonna be blamed
for eating the bodies and stuff oh she's in
there she's in the Asylum I'm a different
person now a person who uses curse words and
kicks orderlies and sees things that aren't
there
this might get lucky for once in your miserable
life wow there clearly should have been a
Jennifer's Body too with her let's go needy's
body oh cool needy's body go kill Adam Brody
is this the only Power she got oh there it
is okay [Music] yeah like all kinds of powers
but I guess she doesn't need to feed
[Music] ah so I guess that's stuff that they
do dump does go somewhere do you think she
killed the mom no so why'd she ditch the murder
of it uh but that's a different murder weapon
oh that's not the box cutter you right yeah
that's why they had that line viewers like
yourself that was a bad moment for me for
sure East towards Madison up in lunch area
I know this guy following this rock band must
be one hell of a group that's Hendricks tonight's
going to be their last show
oh she's gonna kill the band all right cool
yeah shoulder we should see that there should
be another movie this is awesome so
oh my God there's more
[Music] okay maroon 5. this is their last
show
here it is they kept filming that's good
[Music]
this was a different time in the early 2000s
where they were not afraid to show what the
entire sequel was in a post credit I feel
like there's a longer version of this movie
out there
all right wow I'm really into the soundtrack
what did you think Roxy stronger that was
awesome I mean like I we've heard great things
about it but I didn't know if it had just
been over hyped and not all of the powers
are like full extended things make complete
sense but it's so good and fun that I don't
really care yeah that's probably the best
way to put it because it didn't bother me
that all of a sudden you can float I don't
care that's great let me see it yeah I had
no idea what to expect going in all I heard
was that it was a a fun movie and that Megan
Fox is actually really good in it that's all
I ever heard was Megan Fox's actually they
also has a vampire movie and I feel like that
term is used so loosely yeah what would you
say after watching it is this a vampire film
or no it's probably the most efficient way
to describe it's the same way people call
Last of Us a zombie show where you're like
yeah I mean it's kind of a zombie thing but
that's not a zombie show though I know but
it's like the easiest way to explain it but
do you want me to explain to you why it's
not please don't
I I understand why people would say it's a
it's a vampire thing completely because it's
like okay yeah she feeds off people but that
sets you up for a whole different kind of
movie I think when someone says that you think
you're gonna go into uh you think there'd
be a little bit more rules associated with
it and whatnot but totally and then I wrote
the entire movie oh yeah I appreciate that
that did not at all affect my viewing experience
I did not a one minute go oh yeah she's right
they're targeting all these like jock virgins
in here uh that was not the film at all I
do feel like there's a longer version out
there you know what I'm very curious I'm gonna
just quickly Google right now you were saying
that a longer version currently exists or
there's a longer cut to have been made left
on The Cutting Room floor I feel like there's
probably I mean I feel yeah the latter okay
um I feel like there definitely could be a
sequel that would be awesome to this not that
everything needs an effing sequel this movie
is just great as it is everybody extended
version it is an extended version yeah I had
a feeling there were parts of the way the
movie was edited and knowing this director's
other work like I bet this movie actually
breathed a little bit better and took its
time and more scenes why don't we watch that
version oh because I didn't know it about
it until five seconds ago again I just had
I actually thought that this was so tight
though like the the cut the edit was really
really tight solid there's none of the things
that were kind of strange and it's bothered
me it was just like oh okay I'm gonna fill
in the blanks here and sometimes I filled
in the blanks wrong yeah we're really good
at helping the movie out throwing a good alley
oop to the film I feel like my adjustment
it was an interesting choice I think it could
have helped help to flesh it out uh the world
a little bit more I think this is one of those
movies I think two would also be cooler on
a re-watch because there was a lot more thematically
going on on its mind than I was ex I I thought
it would be a little bit more just of a straightforward
like pulpy sexual Thriller kind of film and
it wasn't I was like okay there's a lot of
commentary about adolescent angst and this
also uh what people will do to sell out for
fame and and striving for that and even Jennifer
was because I didn't even get it that sense
until the very end with her and needy when
needy was saying how she used to be popular
and actually takes laxatives now to stay skinny
all these things I didn't pick up on any of
that from Jennifer throughout the movie that
that was something she sort of craved did
you no I agree with that I do think that like
if we're really dissecting this Jennifer's
character seemed super popular at the beginning
super popular in the middle and super Popular
by the end she's always being asked out by
the hottest people anybody she talks to will
go anywhere with her she can convince anybody
of anything in class everybody kind of like
knows that she's the [__] popular girl
so then when when needy all of a sudden is
like two years ago when you were relevant
right I thought you would relevant this whole
time definitely definitely again like didn't
really bother me but if they wanted to Pepper
that in a little more if that was supposed
to be the big reveal like she used to be cool
now she's not that's why she's doing all this
I really feel like it was because she was
in love with needy and she and she was really
the needy one oh yes well done yes yes see
some of my points are sound very impressive
very impressive let's see if you can maintain
the rest of our conversation now okay uh fine
let me throw it back at you before I think
about something brilliant at the end of the
day who did you like better Jennifer and Edie
I mean Jennifer is the more captivating performer
to watch I think I think needy is a more fleshed
out character the one with more Dimensions
I would say though that like I get why people
talked about but she's kind of utilized like
that way in in the film itself they want her
to be a bit mysterious and for her when she's
on screen to really count like needy's The
Kill the character with the character Arc
she's the one who really develops she's the
one with more exploration and I do think this
movie was a little had a little too much on
it that's why I'm actually very I feel like
we should just watch the Extended Cut I wish
I was aware of that before filming why didn't
I do that because I didn't know about it until
after we were done filming the reaction to
the theatrical cut that's so strange so should
we start again no no no no let's keep this
train rolling um she put the movie on the
extenders I'm okay right now we got this maybe
we could just find the extended cut scenes
and I'll just implement it into the reaction
so yeah I do think that because with all they
had on their mind there were there were times
where it was kind of zigzagging for me where
I'm like I'm not sure what to really focus
on but what I thought that this movie had
going so well for it was they had this that
angsty grungy like Gothic dark tone throughout
and because of its strange ethereal teenager
Vibe its tone was always keeping me interested
even when I was like okay this is kind of
a bit of a zigzagging experience because I
was like all right is this really going to
be about Jennifer anedi's friendship is that
what this is really about is this going to
be about them evolving as teenagers uh you
know it's like what are the parallels between
adolescence and this morphing of mutation
she's going through there were there were
so many things that I thought they wanted
to comment on and uh was it always the smoothest
no but was it always entertaining yes and
I think at the end of the day with a movie
like this that's what counts the most is like
it was a very very entertaining film like
I was never bored one second totally the whole
time I was like what do you think's Happening
Here what do you think's going on next um
and I was very entertained too also I think
that I am more willing to be lenient with
movies like this because give me a teenage
girl movie and I watch it 10 out of 10 times
like I love coming age films I love things
that take place in high school I love the
juxtaposition between Jennifer and needy and
like how they are navigating their way through
school and and one of them being much more
just like classic mean girl and the other
one being the nerdier one both of them being
super hot though and actually neither of them
being nerdy in any way shape or form I love
that like I'm a big CW free-form head so not
that this is like that because obviously this
is a more intense I know or people hate the
word elevated now but elevated version of
that which I appreciated the I think if they
were going to try to spice it up a little
bit we could have improved some of our B and
C characters like we got both of their moms
for a second at one random Point yeah um but
nothing no idea about really either of them
and then we got the brother of crispy guy
it was named Chris chip Chips uh sister who
made an appearance and it was like take pictures
with your sister and it's like what happened
there uh then I guess his mom was in it for
a second even chip just a general call and
we didn't get to know that much the dude that
was The Jock that had the best day of his
life with Megan Fox before he got eaten alive
as lasagna like all these kind of characters
where it's just like okay that's there's not
that much there you know I'm not rooting for
any of them at all so it doesn't really matter
what happens to them I think what they could
have done going off what you're saying is
make the town because there was so much emphasis
on what the band did and then the town coming
in I mean what the band did and how I was
trying to Spotlight on the town blah blah
and I think if they made this small town Vibe
feel more alive and see how they're really
being affected by it because like when when
they when they're talking with not crispy
man now you got the second one uh when Chip's
mom is like here's the pepper spray have you
seen about the the kids being murdered I was
like I wasn't even really aware that the town
was aware about the murders of these of these
boys that was happening and I think if we
witnessed some of how the town was being affected
and changing by these circumstances and events
that just would have helped it feel a little
bit more lived in um you know where I'm thinking
that might be where where what the extent
of God yeah probably yes no you are not incorrect
at all I do think that if they're if there's
something in there probably is that like the
reveal that this man is lasagna in the forest
we see his parents kind of see it but we don't
see yes the news going around uh we have that
one radio station that was kind of interesting
too that you got 80s Vibes at the beginning
I got 90s Vibes then we start seeing the flip
phone we hear the cars from 2003. yeah you
know like okay this is actually 2000s movie
but it did really have nostalgic 90s Vibes
to me well yeah it's kind of like those movies
um I I forget the arrows in them are movies
like I've seen movies like Heather's have
you seen Heather's 80s Heathers and then I
thought of I haven't actually seen Cruel Intentions
but everything I've seen A Cruel Intentions
I was kind of getting the Vibes of that's
one of my favorite five movies of all time
really that's top five I think so yeah what
are the other five four Goodwill Hunting Princess
Bride Role Models cool intentions uh Wizard
of Oz like you had to squeeze cruelty screens
in there no no you were like it's definitely
I say cruel attention so I'm gonna mention
yeah top 10 if you've heard for years I've
been telling I love that movie I love love
love that movie it is so good it did have
kind of Cruel Intentions Vibes except that's
not a horror movie although the stuff that's
happening is after yeah but sort of that like
surreal offbeat path in the high school that
I thought this movie was uh at least aiming
to do I was appreciating because there were
some interesting directing choices I thought
did you think it was scary not really no no
was it like would you would you call this
a horror movie that's that was the fun part
about trying to see what I'd like genre categorize
it as because it's I'm like I guess it's a
horror movie Thriller more it's like a supernatural
High School movie it's kind of Thriller because
like they have moments where they were going
for horror but it never felt truly like a
full-blown horror movie I am very curious
what that Extended Cut is like now what do
you think maybe this is answered the next
time to cut but what do you think the deal
with swirly is what's swirly the water that
was going oh the actual sword yeah yeah this
really thing and then we see where it comes
out but like that kind of has nothing to do
with the plot of the movie at all right yeah
I felt like Jennifer would be dumping bodies
yeah me too like at some point we were gonna
see like I guess the knife pops out there
but the fact that the scientists have been
searching high and low and can't figure out
where it is but it's just going out to this
tree oh my God there's a clear spot right
here did you see all the balls and stuff like
what is the D what was the deal with that
is that where the supernatural Powers come
from or maybe it's some type of commentary
about you know like when we descend to
the depths of Hell everything eventually Rises
to the surface Roxy
[Laughter]
again it didn't really bother me because it
didn't distract me from anything else but
it's just like that was an interesting choice
that we spent time on this swirly thing that
really had nothing to do with yeah we didn't
put the bodies there we didn't say that that's
where the powers came from even though maybe
you could jump to think that yeah you know
what I gotta I gotta find out Jennifer's Body
what's something like you Google Extended
Cut differences we could do that we just go
unanswered questions oh okay facts and expert
answers is there a deeper meaning to Jennifer's
Body feminist film Theory explained that in
the male subconscious female power is inversely
proportional to male power therefore they
cannot coexist because of the fear of emasculation
the more power woman gains the more she is
dehumanized and then punished interesting
I agree if you concur yes uh agree yeah I
don't think female power it always makes me
feel less than so I prefer women do not have
power you wrote it yourself I did submit an
article to uh feministtheoryish.com that's
what I was thinking what's Jennifer attracted
to needy yes written by a feminist Diablo
Cody uh interesting it doesn't really answer
the question what else did Diablo Cody write
uh oh yeah it's a good question let's see
also love the line written by a feminist written
by Bruno self-proclaimed feminist this can't
be anti-feminism because it's written by somebody
who claims they're a feminist I guess it's
fem is it a 2009 film I don't really look
at it as like feminist or not feminist I just
like the movie yeah I didn't really see it
as like anything that was oh he did Dolly
I love [__] Dolly I haven't seen tally
oh it's a good one we would go up go up like
down no up I want to say the most Telly Jennifer's
Body Juno young adult oh okay oh yeah so they
do write a lot of these like coming of age
stories okay I mean overall it was a fun film
with a lot of exciting visual motifs good
soundtrack I was so into the soundtrack that
was one of the best parts for me I could tell
you're really digging on that side you know
what I also really loved the costumes it was
very very early 2000s yes like the juicy the
jean skirt the um just the like stripes on
the tops yeah the polos for the guys all that
too very much was aware what was your favorite
outfit you know when she was wearing the Evil
Dead shirt
the part of the video where you try to burn
your tongue or I think you two would get mad
at us for trying to do that to be like you're
encouraging kids to try dangerous things it
was crazy how her tongue like I can disintegrate
it was a good effect yeah it was cool I've
never seen that is it gif GIF yeah how do
you say GIF gif it's graphic so GIF but I
think they said that it's Jiff really messing
with us yeah yeah and a lot of good slang
in here too okay what's your favorite salty
good never heard that before I loved Jello
man I'm not letting Jello go I've never heard
that ever applied in any context in my life
Green Jello did people do kids talk like that
did you talk like that in high school I do
feel like this movie made up a ton of terminology
that at the time if it had if I had seen it
when it came out I would have used okay for
sure yeah one of those because what did this
year did this drop in 2003 2009 2009 yeah
okay we have IMDb right in front of us yeah
yep see it now
even as you said that I was like we're not
even on this movie it's literally right there
in 2009 so I was graduating high school that
year okay so I for sure
what yeah it's all been alive yeah 2001. because
I graduated high school yeah I'm a vampire
I stay so young because all the blood that
I suck
but I definitely like if I if this has come
out and they've been saying things like salty
and I saw a guy that I thought was cute I'd
been like he's salty definitely it's just
so insulted I'm like that just sounds uh off-putting
me totally now we use now Salty's uses like
they're bitter like something yeah but Jello
that's a really good one oh my God you're
Green Jello you could never wait what is jello
used in the as jealous yes you're so jello
you're so jealous you're actually the Green
Jello that's how feminist ride movies apparently
yeah I do wonder how he came up with some
of this terminology was he just like isn't
Diablo a woman oh really oh that makes more
sense then oh wait no I'm not sure Johnny
who later became her uh yeah yeah okay I think
so it says writer producer actress okay we
don't know the uh gender identification it's
interesting that her name or their name is
devil oh really is that what Diablo stands
for
isn't that you know what I need to stop like
believing you on things because I'm always
like how fascinating yeah well name meaning
Spanish for definitely you nailed it oh yeah
Diablo that's cool oh clever yeah I mean I
like supernatural horror stuff I guess I would
still categorize it as that for sure it was
doing a lot but I thought Megan Fox was excellent
she was so like she was seductive but beyond
that she had some great scenes where this
is most the most I've ever really believed
her like fully believed her in every scene
she was in well what else are you comparing
it to transforming you know Transformers yeah
yeah I saw this one movie she did with Simon
Pegg ages ago where she was finding it what
about Amanda Seyfried I don't know her work
too well other than like Mean Girls and Ted
too I like I I always assumed Amanda seyfried's
a great actress she's so so good I thought
they were both very believable and I thought
they had great chem some of my favorite scenes
were just them together and I wish the movie
kind of did more of that was was just them
hanging out because I thought they had really
great chemistry they did I I think it's really
difficult for to do what Megan Fox did here
which was like be believably an utter [__]
yeah like it's actually the way that she did
it um but you still kind of love her character
she really nailed it I felt like they both
had the right pitch of tone for what the director
wanted to go for with this film definitely
because you need a certain type of surrealistic
height and tone but you can't overdo it or
also becomes on like not believable and I
think with two very different performances
they both found that right middle ground in
order to make it still believable in a heightened
reality she was the the Regina George of this
movie yes in a lot of ways yeah you have semen
girls yeah I love Mean Girls It's really good
yeah is it one of your top five favorite movies
no cruel intense yeah but Mean Girls is out
there Legally Blonde is up there you seen
that one yeah yeah okay just checking okay
have you seen The Matrix Revolutions no I
only saw the first Matrix I only saw it this
year I know this year 2023 that they said
22 yeah in the last year I mean very technical
here yeah I feel like wow when did you turn
on me what happened sorry all right no usually
I try to help you out how are we going to
expect them to love me when I can't even get
you no I got you I got you covered oh twist
the knife well uh we'll drain it out of ten
then we'll call it a night I just died and
you didn't I know I did a bit of being hi
caring I was done maybe a eight and a half
I really like that that's really high you're
so bad as hard what's yours 7.5 okay really
good yeah that's solid yes seven to seven
point five it's going down a little bit do
you think it's a four and a half it's gone
it fluctuates no I thought that was awesome
I enjoyed the hell out of that movie have
you seen the invitation remember she did no
oh that is one of my favorite horror movies
really yeah so this isn't as good that's a
what I appreciate is it's like the invitation
is if you want to talk about elevated horror
that is is it is so like such a slow build
it is entirely like so slow and you you're
the whole time you're like I don't know what's
going where this movie's going but I am uncomfortable
and I don't even know why who's in it um have
you seen upgrade the the tech one with uh
dude Tom not Tom Hardy but it looks like Tom
Hart Logan Marshall agrees okay then maybe
I think I saw it on an airplane that's how
you watched it I think so people were talking
about it for a while and then I think I saw
it there oh what a terrible way to experience
that I actually don't know how much I I think
I saw it I don't remember movies perfectly
that's the truth about me I remember everything
about TV shows I I movies I do not remember
movies I do have a hard time recalling especially
if I'm under a certain type of influence tired
yeah that's what it is I'm very tired sometimes
in life you're just hot and tired it's tired
you're a good mood but tired you know how
it goes guys uh yeah that he's in it but it's
really it's a gray film and it's very much
like not this it's it's super slow is the
guy from upgrade an invitation or yeah yeah
yeah and he's uh I thought he was phenomenal
when I met him that was the first thing I
told him was like your work performance in
the invitation blew my mind why'd you meet
him I was at the premiere of upgrade you're
so fancy yeah yeah you've like interviewed
super famous people though yeah interviewed
Bohemian Rhapsody people yeah I did do that
in Vegas they flew me there on a private jet
it's crazy really private jet yeah good for
you with the cast and then I was front row
to see Queen and got to hang out with uh Brian
May and Roger Taylor oh you've clearly ridden
that momentum all the way to this channel
that's how I got here